We have a voicemail number, which you can
call anytime.
The number is two one nine two David P..
Here is a call from a guy who is very happily
voting Trump.
Take a listen.
You and I am voting for president.
By the way, the requisite show playing in
the background, it's always it's a staple
of these phone calls.
And no, a sit up and all you want to.
I am voted for president pro the best president
I have believe.
God bless you and thank you.
Right.
So remember, you can't talk a guy out of that
in the 10 weeks we have left.
Don't even bother.
We just have to get the vote out.
Remember that we've got a great bonus show
for you today.
We will talk about reports of New York City's
demise being greatly exaggerated.
We will talk about differences in coverage
of the conventions on corporate media and
much, much more.
Make sure to get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member.
Join Pacman dot com or a patron at patrie
on dot com slash David Pakman share.